all right looks like we're now live for
the March ask me anything session I've
got myself set up here in the studio
upstairs a little bit better lighting
then downstairs and it might be a little
bit quieter as well we'll see how how it
comes out I'm just going to post a few
links well I wait for the questions to
come in we've already got 9 viewers
that's that's pretty cool
Saturday's tend to work better than than
others so let me post in the social
media stuff yeah so I'll just bring you
up to speed a little bit about about
myself and the month while I'm waiting
for for questions to come in so it
hasn't been super productive been I've
been sick for about well the last week
and a half my wife first got a flu and
then you know I was helping to take care
of her and do some of the things that
she would usually be doing and then I
got sick and we've both been trying to
continue on with work but but it's kind
of counterproductive you know we
probably should have just taken days off
and not trying to work but I get a bit
of work done I haven't gotten that much
video work done unfortunately because at
the times that I'm scheduled to do it
sometimes I'm a little bit too tired to
have my you know presence of mind that I
need in order to say something
relatively on track and intelligent
about about stuff and you know you don't
want to be low-energy when you're doing
it at the same time it's been kind of a
cool month I did have kind of a
milestone my first television appearance
very short you know about a all told I
think my type it was about a minute and
a half but it's on this ask the expert
segment on our local NBC affiliate so
that that's kind of cool
I have been meaning to blog about that
and the experience of going
TV was very different than then you know
video and yourself are doing like what
we're doing right here because you get
these big cameras looking at you and the
lights and and it's it's yeah it's a bit
different so we can talk about that if
you're interested all right now that
I've posted this stuff I better get over
and see if people have any questions no
not not yet
doesn't look like it let me make sure
though let's see if this is actually
going because they're there been a few
issues sometimes with YouTube and making
sure let's go to live control room then
a few issues sometimes with like working
all these different controls and man
they've got new features already nope we
don't we don't have any yet so okay so
oh I misspoke there's a whole bunch of
things already alright so let me start
at the start can all ask do you browse
dank memes I'm not exactly sure what
dank I think dank is like the equivalent
of cool are good but I'm so far out of
the meme culture that I don't really
know I mean I see a lot of memes on
Facebook and and Twitter and
occasionally people have been posting
them and Linkedin but I don't spend an
awful lot of time people send me memes
which is cool I like I like seeing that
but I haven't really thought that much
about about meme culture well here's a
good question from Carl bad recently I
got into a large fight with my
girlfriend stemming from the fact that I
refer to Cicero as Thole alla Gibbon she
has mad at me for reasons I don't get if
I could get your stamp of approval it
would go a long way towards repairing
the relationship well I mean if your
girlfriend cares anything about what I
have to say that's quite interesting
I mean people did call Cicero Tully it
was it was quite common almost like a
code name you could say for people in
the know I mean I see a lot of
references to that in the 18th century
so I mean this isn't the sort of thing
that I think people ought to be fighting
about but then again you know if I think
about some of the things I've argued
about with with friends or romantic
partners in the past or even my wife
fairly recently usually they're they're
kind of irrational oh good luck with
with all of that let me take Conners
questions I love your videos dr. Sadler
they're very nice to hear that very
interesting and engaging what's your
opinion of dr. Jordan Peterson so people
ask me this quite quite often and I
think that you know Peterson I can't say
that much of buttocks I haven't read his
recent book and I've only read like
little snippets of his his past book
I've seen some of his videos and talks
and stuff like that he strikes me here's
here's my sort of general impression he
strikes me as somebody who and I see a
lot of people who wind up in this sort
of situation who in some respects was
not really prepared for the fame that he
has now encountered I mean we know this
from ancient philosophy that fame or
glory or social reputation whatever we
want to call it and and all the other
things that go along with it wealth
access but also the requirement to sort
of declare yourself on one side or
another on many things it takes a toll
on people and and it takes some some
preparation and it seems like like
because he became a darling on the right
and he has all these these people you
know essentially easy he's got two kinds
of people involved with him right one
one is the group of people that are
saying oh he's the devil he's he's
terrible he's a sign of everything
that's wrong with you know whatever you
want and then he's also got you know a
lot of people saying that he's the best
thing since sliced bread and so
brilliant and and all of that I think
it's very difficult to keep your head
when you're encountering that sort of
thing and and you know my impression is
that he's kind of bought into this
notion that he is this this you know
representative defender of Western
culture and and all of that I'll say
this too that if and this goes not just
for Peterson but but for so many others
if the idea is is that that Western
culture and and something traditional as
what what he's defending perhaps that's
not really worth keeping it and I say
that by way of saying that what we
understand is like the heritage of the
last or something like that tends to be
much richer than what people on the
right and definitely what people on the
left reduce it to and that's part of why
I don't end up taking you know stances
like that because he asked me about you
know so and so what do you think about
so-and-so's philosophy Aristotle Plato
the Stoics and I'll be like no it's
complicated you know where would they
fit in on right or left well they'd be
critical of both you know and and I
think that that Peterson has sort of
been been attracted almost by a kind of
political gravitational force into the
circuit of the right so there that's my
my opinion again I really ought to make
the time to read his stuff so that I can
say something more intelligent about him
that's that's that's on me for not doing
that let's see canal asks have you read
Leo Strauss his lectures on Cicero I
haven't so I don't I don't have anything
to say about that oh it was a really
interesting one from Corbeau do you
since you know quite a few European
languages I was wondering what your
stance on Native American languages was
should we try to keep them or revitalize
them I mean I'm kind of a romantic in
the old sense in that way in that I am
happy to see languages survive it's
interesting because when I was like
doing a lot of philosophy of language
work and also you know like doing some
of the groundwork for learning
additional languages back in graduate
school I was looking at some of the
works that had been done to try to
preserve Native American languages and
some of them the the the Jesuits in
particular had played in a very
important role in you know coming up
with grammars and stuff like that
because they had a different way of
doing missions and so some what really
what you really need is you have to have
like a written grammar or else it
becomes very difficult to preserve the
language
you also need native speakers you know
and that's that's tough as well you know
I think just and this is European
language is not Native American
languages I think back to like my family
and the fact that on my mother's side
you know they're french-canadian and
they they spoke French at home and my
mother's generation in her the house
that she grew up in you know her mother
was from Quebec her dad was a third
generation immigrant but he spoke French
as well and and she didn't learn English
until she was about five or so in in
grammar school and it was very easy to
preserve that because they lived on a
block in Chicago that was almost all
French Canadians and and Menominee
Indians their long-standing connection
between those two groups and you know in
my generation I I grew up hearing French
a lot and learning to speak it you know
in kind of a half-assed way and then you
know she insisted that I should take
like a year in middle school and a year
in high school but that was of course
Parisian French and then I didn't
actually get serious until college and
even then I really wasn't that serious
about it was more like well that's
that's what the old people talk but and
then it became very important as the
older people started dying off there's
very few people in our family who
actually speak French anymore
who especially who speak you know kenta
quoi
and so you know it becomes I tried to
teach my daughter but it was just too
difficult to keep keep it going
and it's unfortunate so I mean that's
French I mean think about the the
challenges involved in keeping
some of the Native American languages
alive in a culture that that simply
doesn't reward that sort of thing so
it's probably enough about that uh the
internet the internet that's great
general thoughts on the lose with or
without guitar II I think that so this
will be very controversial I'm sure I
think that the lose is interesting but I
think that he's really in many respects
overrated I remember when he became like
very fashionable back in in when I was
just finishing up grad school and I
often see people like bringing him up
and I've read a lot of Deleuze you know
and I you know at one time I was
actually like thinking about doing a my
dissertation on dairy I was never
attracted to lose enough to do that but
but I was doing a lot with you know
contemporary French thought and you know
with the lose just as with Dario just
Foucault just as with you know other
other thinkers I think there's a lot of
people who use stuff that they get from
him but they don't really it's very
superficial and I think Deleuze you know
of course could have been okay with that
because the whole rhizome thing and all
that but but I think you know most of
the delusions out there I'm very
unimpressed with and you know the stuff
that I actually liked the best by
Deleuze tended to be his critical essays
you know like his essay for example on
Bartleby the Scrivener
or on the law in Melville very
interesting stuff so yeah so I guess I
always confused belief justification and
truth and the theories of truth and
theories of justifications confuses me
as well that's okay there's a lot of you
know different theories out there some
day I actually want to write a book you
know focused specifically on theories of
truth and I am sort of a if you want to
know my stance and that kind of a
pluralist stance right I think that we
need multiple theories of truth to
actually make sense of it in an adequate
way
but you know yeah it gets it gets tricky
because as we're thinking about look at
what's the nature of truth how are we
justifying things we're doing a meta
inquiry right because we're trying to
formulate our thoughts about that and
oftentimes in relation to other people's
thoughts and at the same time we're
doing exactly that stuff right so that's
that's I wouldn't feel too bad about
that here's a good question from one
manting er how does one become a
philosopher especially nowadays and
perhaps without academic tuition well it
depends on what you understand
philosopher to mean so this is actually
what I got asked about on the the TV
interview all right we have this thing
well philosophies love of wisdoms so if
you love wisdom you're a philosopher
well kinda well maybe if you go to
school and you get a PhD then you're a
philosopher well I have a lot of
colleagues who I wouldn't actually call
philosophers I would say that they teach
philosophy or
things like that but but they're I
wouldn't say that they have you know
sort of the the disposition of a
philosophy I think that so philosophy is
a field that is in in theory able to
extend to everything and it tries to and
when it when it abandons that and it
tries to you know say oh no no no it's
only about language or oh no no it's
only about like you know doing this this
little stuff that that clear stuff up
for science I actually think it ceases
to be philosophy a lot of times when
philosophy becomes too restrictive it
loses its way although I understand the
attraction that people have for that
it's much more manageable you know you
become a philosopher in part I think
that that you know somebody like
Alistair McIntyre is right philosophy is
something like a craft you learn it by
engaging in it by out but also by sort
of retracing what others themselves have
done with it so you read Plato not just
to know what Plato had to say about
stuff so you can regurgitate it later on
and not just so that you can advance
beyond Plato and show how clever you are
but because Plato even if he's wrong on
a lot of stuff at least traced out some
some fundamental paths that we want to
you know think through and then we can
start to adapt them to new circumstances
and likewise with Aristotle or and and
you don't have to feel like you have to
study everybody because that's
impossible these days right
yeah the you just couldn't there's
there's no way that you know maybe maybe
even like in Hegel's time it wasn't it
wasn't truly possible although he
certainly gave it a shot
right but after him you know there's
just too many things so you you you go
at it and you you try to see you know
what encountering other people's thought
will will do with your own thought and
your own life and it's an iterative
process you do it over and over again
and I think it's also helpful to do it
with other people not necessarily like
everything that you do has to be a study
group or something like that but I think
it's good to get other people involved
in it and and sometimes the academic
philosophy can be very good at promoting
that you know but sometimes it stifles
it I've seen that in some places all
right let me take the next one Anna Anna
of Spain I'm starting some self-directed
philosophy study watched your video on
the Euthyphro after reading it and
noticed you told your students there was
a resolution to the dilemma but you
never said what it was I was wondering
what you were getting at there Thanks
love your videos yeah so the Euthyphro
dilemma just to sort of refresh anybody
who doesn't remember what that is it
comes out of Plato's Euthyphro and
actually Plato has Socrates decide for
one side and it gets you know somewhat
changed over the years and it has to do
with the relationship between the divine
and goodness and so one one Fork of the
dilemma is to say God or the gods or
whatever you conceive of as divine loves
or commands or you know whatever verb
you want to substitute there that
whatever is good because it's good so
that there's some sort of stand
prior to or you know you can take God
out of the picture and say you know God
is just recognizing the goodness of
whatever is good the other possibility
is to say no it works the other way
around
whatever it is that's good is good
because God commands it or loves it or
you know again pick whatever verb you
like there and then you get something
that we often call volunteerism where
the very goodness
of things that are good are so because
God you know likes that are commands
that or wants it or whatever and that
seems kind of dicey because and some
people are willing to embrace that say
yeah if God told me tomorrow that you
know black is white and white is black a
okay I'll switch them around if God
tells me that instead of like you know
being faithful to my wife I should sleep
with as many people as possible I'll
just do that you know and that becomes
good most people are kind of
uncomfortable with that but they're also
uncomfortable if they're religious
believers with the notion that you've
got these standards of goodness and then
you can just kind of take out of the
picture so third possibility that you
see in classical theism yeah you know
somebody like Anselm is is really good
with with this is that God you know is
by virtue of being the divine nature God
God already understands what is good and
that flows out of the divine nature but
it's not as if God would like you know
like Anselm says if God were to command
you to lie
he would no longer be God if God were to
you know deliberately sin God would no
longer begun so there's an entry
possibility is somehow the divine nature
unifies goodness and and the nature of
God so that God isn't like obeying some
external criterion or recognizing some
external criterion but it's not just
well whatever God decides you know
suddenly becomes okay god constrains God
you could say in that case Caleb asks
did philosophers or ancient people talk
about synchronicity coincidence or
anything related to
fortune like when Zeno asked if there
was anyone like Socrates to speak with
cratis was passing then well they didn't
use the word synchronicity that's that's
young who likes that sort of thing and
then people following him but yeah they
certainly did they often thought this
was in terms of what they called
Providence right things being arranged
in a certain way by whatever the divine
fate you know
the Stoics actually had a lot of
speculation about this and and much more
than we actually have access to we know
this from reading things like Cicero's
on fate or his much longer work on
divination and so this is kind of a live
issue back in ancient times you know
just chance rule everything or is there
some sort of underlying pattern or for
meaning so yeah they did they didn't
talk about it they didn't talk about it
quite in the same way oh here's a
question from Dan one you have a
profound grip on philosophy and possibly
economics and history why are you not
inevitably a Marxist well so I'm glad
you think I have a profound grip on
philosophy and I stray into history a
lot and I do have an interest in
economics but I cannot say that I'm an
expert on that I probably am much more
conscious of the gaps in my education
than my viewers are now why am I not
inevitably a Marxist because there is
nothing inevitable about being a Marxist
i I'm an eclectic actually there's quite
a few things that I do like about Marx
but there's there's plenty of things
where I think he's gotten things wrong
and I mean we even see this within the
history of Marxism right they have to
engage in quite a bit of revision to
make the Marxist theory work very well
and really if the old joke about poets
probably goes from Marxist you know what
does a Marxist hate more than anything
else
another Marxist who doesn't believe
exactly the same interpretation
so you know that that's that's probably
enough of an answer to that I will
mention that I've been rereading George
Sorel recently and I remember an
interesting passage in there where he
was saying you know Marx thought the
Revolution and you know sort of the
proletariat would have to go this way
but why can't it also go this way into
something more conservative as well and
that's that's one of the big problems
with like any sort of historical
determinism it's quite difficult to do
that sim hello dr. Stadler I'd like to
ask could you see yourself doing a
series on philosophy of emotion what and
who and how would you recommend to read
on emotion from before modern philosophy
well it's a good good set of questions
yeah I could definitely see myself doing
a series on philosophy of emotion and I
you know I'll probably not only do a
video series but also build some classes
on that as well
who would I recommend to read on emotion
well a lot of the classics you know
Plato is is very important for that
although he more raises problems and
gives you answers and then Aristotle I
mean rhetoric book two is all about the
emotions and then you know there's a
very important discussions in many of
the other works as well
Stoics had a lot to say about emotions
and by the way there is a real there
there are some good secondary works you
know so like for example Margaret ravers
book the stuff you know stoicism and
emotion is a great place to go for that
sort of stuff we don't have quite so
much from the epicurean tradition it's
just in part cuz we don't have as many
works from them preserved but we have a
lot of stuff from from the ancients
Plutarch is also very interesting to
read as well you know these middle plate
mists and Plutarch is kind of cool too
because you know he's got his his
philosophical works and then he's got
those lives and they they kind of
connect up with each other right and
then you know we can go on and on and on
you know in in the early Christian era
you know most of my
work on emotion tends to circle around
the motion around anger you know
lactantius has this wonderful piece
which is called on on divine anger or
I'm God's anger and in it he sort of
like summarizes the other philosophical
schools and then he's like you know
doing what early Christians had to do it
just makes sense not only of the culture
that they're in but also scriptures and
the experiences that they're having any
takes his best stab at that and ends up
talking a lot more about human anger
than about dividing gur and it keeps on
going you know there's a lot of great
thinkers I've done I've done work on you
know like Thomas Aquinas on anger
Augustine on anger the Phil oculina has
all sorts of interesting stuff
discussions about anger as a matter of
fact it's one of the best or most
interesting translations of the two most
write the the middle part in Plato that
gets angry and it's concerned with honor
in between reason and the appetites is
the incandescent part I've seen that as
a nice translation in the English
version of the Phil okay Leah and then
you know it continues on into modern
philosophy there's some really great
works in modern philosophy like des
cartes treatise on the passions of the
soul written in response to Princess
Elizabeth so yeah there's there's
there's there's a lot of good stuff
there Richler I started reading Simone
de Beauvoir as the second sex and I was
wondering if you're planning to make
more videos about her other feminist
thinkers yeah I
one thing I've meant to do for a long
time and I put it as one of the like
goals that I'll take on when I reach a
certain level of supported patreon is to
restart that existentialism series that
I started so long ago and de Beauvoir
I'll definitely be doing parts of the
second sex and the ethics of ambiguity
and you know I might I might do
[Music]
well you know one of her literary works
as well and I have done videos on other
feminist thinkers you know somebody who
I work on quite a bit as Mary
Wollstonecraft so you know you've got I
think at this point seven or eight
videos I've done on her all some of
which were four classes some of which
were four talks I mean who else you know
Hana Hana rent is not you know I don't
think she'd quite you know classify
herself as a feminist but she's
definitely you know very interesting
thank her and and yeah I do that it's
interesting because when I posted one of
my Wollstonecraft's Ochs even before
anybody had actually watched it because
this is within a minute of posting it I
got two different responses both from
opposite ends of the spectrum
one was from a woman who said Oh typical
you know middle-aged white male talking
about you know women trying to claim her
for his own and all that and of course
she had watched the talk she just
reacted to the fact that I am indeed a
middle-aged white man you know who's
talking about Wollstonecraft and on the
other end there is some you know alright
kid who has you know on and on about you
know women can't be philosophers blah
blah blah blah blah and you know what's
really too bad you know that that
neither of them even bothered to hear
what with what what was being said oh
wow a lot of more questions coming up
zooming through
let me grab one by nature boy
do you follow a certain philosophy in
your own life yeah I do
I I'm an eclectic you know I draw up on
different philosophical traditions those
that I draw up on the most would be you
know the Aristotelian and the stoic and
and the broad plate in this tradition
some Christian writers existentialists
and I would say you know draw on some
stuff from the psychoanalytic tradition
rather selectively and some stuff from
the dialectical
as well ashley writes hope you and your
wife feel better soon
thanks that that's that's very nice of
you
yeah and you get these flu bugs you know
and we're in an era when when I think
sicknesses are gonna get worse because
we've made so many things resistance
well why do you find monotheism to be
more philosophically cogent than
polytheism I'm not sure I'm not sure I
ever said it was more philosophically
cogent but I I do I mean in a way you
know you could say that there's there's
[Music]
there's monotheism in a lot of different
senses you know I particularly like
these these thinkers like Chesterton or
Lewis the writer also the you know come
on the writer Lucian oddish
who are able to take you know sort of
the the pagan polytheistic mass of gods
and somehow assimilate them into a
monotheistic context similar to what's
done in if a religion too by the way you
know where you've got all the run and
then you've got the Arisa who are the
the deputies right we see this over and
over and over again this this thematic
the Stoics also had something kind of
similar to that there was god Zeus and
then there were the gods and they helped
to you know to take care of the universe
you know I think that that although it's
fun to read you know the ancient myths
and stuff like that the notion of the
universe being a portion between
fundamentally opposed beings who none of
whom I actually are like on top of
everything I you know I think if you're
gonna have a god a Divine Principle in
there may as well make it you know
capital G God in a way and I know that's
not a great argument there but that's
just sort of touching on it but I mean
you're you're talking about something
that would take much longer time to
discuss Trevor if determinism is choice
what would be a great way to move the
zeitgeist forward the goal to move as
much human diversity into the future
possible big projects multiplanetary
living I don't know what if determinism
is choice would mean I mean are you
talking about a compatibilism where we
where we we work within a determinism
but we contribute to that determinism
and sort of every once in a while kind
of it adds something new to it well I
think we get you know put that aside and
then talk about how do we move the
zeitgeist forward to move as much human
diversity in the future as possible I
guess that's a good thing I mean a lot
of human diversity is diversity of how
screwed up people are so maybe we'd want
to prune some of that off you know but
yeah I mean it depends on what we're
talking about in terms of diversity
right and I would I would love to see us
reach out to the stars but I don't I
don't foresee that happening in our
lifetime you know it's interesting
because I was born in 1970 and and the
fact that we'd landed on the moon was
really really big news and I wanted to
be an astronaut when I was like four or
five six years old and you know I
remember like how slow everything went
and you know I remember the the
Challenger explosion watching it on
television in our classroom and
realizing that whatever was going to
happen in terms of mankind in the Stars
was not going to be like the sci-fi
stuff that we we had all right let me go
down oh here's a good question from Karl
recently in your ideas that matter video
you and your interlocutor while
discussing santiana reference non
reductive materialism can you explain
this concept further yeah so non
reductive materialism is exactly what it
sounds like you say that everything is
material but you don't try to say well
whatever doesn't neatly fit into
whatever materialist schema we've got is
all bs so it means that you're
challenged it means that if you want to
be a thoroughgoing materialist then you
need to be let's let's sort of bring in
another guy well
James right William James says the
empiricists were not empirical enough
empiricism is about experience and if
your empiricism is too rigid
you can't account for a lot of the
experiences that people have other than
saying oh that's all illusion or they
don't know what they're talking about
and when you do that you have an
impoverished world that you're
projecting onto there if materialism is
really any good it's got to be able to
explain and not just explain away why
people would talk about say spiritual
realities Hegel is somebody who does
that by the way in the phenomenology
over and over and over again Hegel will
say ideas matter insofar as you can put
them into some sort of actuality that's
where you know he doesn't say this but
that's what the proverbial rubber meets
the road but you gotta have the whole of
the idea not just you know whatever fit
into a nice little little box Adam how
fast you read books how to develop speed
reading I don't speed read
I think speed reading is nonsense you
know it could be good for technical
stuff it's it's not worth doing for
philosophy because philosophy and
anything else that's like it you know
thoughtful history thoughtful political
science thoughtful economics you need to
actually slow down and think and you
can't force ideas you have to actually
grow with them how fast do I read books
depends on the books so if it's a work
of philosophy oftentimes I'm rereading
rather than reading these days and I
also have you know some advantage in
that I can draw on a lot of background
knowledge and previous experience but I
I take philosophy books pretty slow if
it's a novel I'll probably read it
pretty fast you know because it's not
demanding quite so much of me unless the
writing is extraordinarily good or it's
very philosophically astute or something
like that
so Riley hi dr. Sandler what's your most
important piece of advice for writing a
good philosophy paper that's a tough one
so I'll give you the bit of advice that
one of my dissertation advisors gave me
the only good dissertation is a done
dissertation don't be a perfectionist
you can always rewrite you can always
add later on but what's most important
is actually getting something out there
externalized rather rather than going
down a million rabbit holes of research
you know or worrying about it too much
lana asks how do we know that we
understand the real meaning of
philosophical propositions and that
we're not confused linguistically and
epistemologically when do we know we're
getting the real meaning I'm not even
sure how how you would you would answer
that I suppose it's kind of an
approximative process you know it's it's
not something I I think about too much I
mean it is a really good question how do
we know that we don't have sort of
systematic biases that are messing us up
we really only realize that when we you
know run into something like here here
would be an example of how it could
happen you're reading you're reading
something and you're like this doesn't
seem right at all I mean why would
somebody who I think is pretty
intelligent right this crazy crap and
you're like well maybe maybe I'm getting
the words wrong
maybe I need to look at look at this
more carefully and then maybe you go to
secondary literature to find out about
it you know I mean this happens all the
time with the half-hour Hegel project in
the videos right people are like you
know Hegel said this and then I actually
got the book right here you know so
Miller's translation of Hegel says blah
blah blah blah blah and you know and
you're like well I mean Miller's trying
to translate something that's rather
difficult
Hegel's prose is not easy he was not a
great stylist and he's trying to grapple
with some really complicated ideas so
don't automatically take this word to
mean what you think it means in a non
philosophical context and then you know
just sort of deduce things from it it
usually takes those kind of experiences
where we become aware and then you just
I don't know you just keep working at it
will asks you got a lot of lectures on
the Stoics what's your take on Spinoza
and the Stoics is Spinoza just a
different flavor of the stomach's you
know one of Spinoza's earliest books is
principles of Cartesian philosophies
vanozza is a Cartesian he's not he's not
actually a stoic you could say he's
influenced in a certain respect by
meiosis ISM but no he's doing his own
thing and he's using Cartesian stuff at
the beginning and also some stuff he
borrows from Hobbes too and the track
Tata Steel or eco politico's but he's
really he's really doing his own thing
he's he's I don't think his pantheism is
really that similar to that of the
Stoics I mean there is a similar
emphasis on trying to understand the
emotions but you know the idea that he
has of the emotions is not a stoic one I
would say all right Lyndon very
latestarter but I just started reading
the Republic kind of amused at how some
of the arguments sound a bit like
sophistry yeah and there's like two ways
that happens right it's somebody who's
not Socrates making a bad argument
sometimes actually saying like Lakhan
does in book two I don't believe this
argument myself Socrates but I want to
see how you respond to it let me put it
out there right and sometimes it
Socrates and so you can ask yourself
well why would Plato who was a smart guy
have his favorite guy his teacher saying
things that you know a little bit of
analysis could reveal to have weaknesses
and so maybe it's like Plato creating an
obstacle course Russ maybe we're
supposed to be in dialogue with the
dialogues and and go a little bit
further beyond them I mean that would
fit Plato's view on the written word so
yeah
let's see here I can't I can't
I have no idea what name that is how to
learn ancient Greek for Chinese it is
extremely difficult for me I don't know
if I have any any advice that would be
particularly helpful for that I just
don't you know I don't know though the
field well enough one Matt younger would
you say going to vote on national
elections is duty and obligation of a
citizen if so why um yeah I think it's I
think it's a duty and obligation but
it's it's kind of mitigated by the fact
that we don't really have a hell of a
lot of choice in some circumstances I
mean we're Russians obligated to go to
the polls when you know Putin is pretty
much going to win you know there's a big
debate about this should you know should
you not vote because that way you're not
you know ratifying an election that you
really can't believe in or should you
cast a protest vote for one of the other
candidates this is a big problem here as
well something that you know important
philosophers have actually taken stands
on I mean I got into some some
discussions with Paul Griffiths back in
the Bush era about exactly you know how
one ought to be voting or casting a
principled non vote as Alistair McIntyre
called it you know what what should we
be doing so yeah that's that's kind of a
you know it's an interesting point I'm
happy that here in Wisconsin in my state
I am you know instead of like living in
New York where I actually registered as
a Republican not because I like the
Republican Party but because I wanted to
have a little bit of the vote that count
and you know like in the primaries
because they don't have open primaries
and the Democratic machine runs pretty
much everything they want there here in
Wisconsin we have open primaries which
means that you can be a registered
independent like I am and you get to
vote in the Republican one or the
Democrat one you get to pick and choose
and we're a battleground state
you know our votes actually count
whereas if you live in Illinois to the
south of us
not really you know it's a blue state
and it's probably gonna stay blue the
whole time or if you went a little bit
further south you got red states that
are just gonna stay red you know in
cases like that maybe it doesn't matter
if you vote you know so that's that's
something to think about in in guilds if
I'm sure I've mispronounced that I
wonder how you're not losing your voice
well that's an interesting point I guess
it's like a muscle right you use it a
lot and you'll be okay with it I
remember when I was teaching in the
prisons when I first started teaching I
would sometimes have I would I would
drink tea and I would have these cough
drops and I'd bring them along every
single day because by the end of the day
I'd been you know not just talking in
the classroom but usually having to
shout over fans you know air
conditioners stuff like that for about
seven to eight hours and my vocal cords
were actually like sore you know by the
end of the day where I could barely talk
so who's this is there a proper email
address for you yep Greg at reason I Oh
calm easy enough to find it's like on my
youtube it's on my facebook it's
everywhere catalogers catching a live
stream of yours is incredibly exciting
glad that you you feel that way
[Music]
JJ yes what is your view on
post-modernism I think most people who
talk about post-modernism don't have any
idea what they're talking about both the
people who are like for post-modernism
and the people who are against it I
don't take anybody very seriously unless
they actually have you know show me that
they they know something about you know
the now traditional use of the term if
it's just like well you know relativism
just call it relatives and don't call it
post-modernism because relativism has
been around since the the ancient period
right there's nothing particularly
postmodern about it you know a lot of
people use it as
a boogeyman but you know that's just a
sign of I don't you either
Minoo or their opportunistically trying
to rile people up um what do I on Dario
what do I think of noam chomsky
Chomsky's political views I pretty much
ignore Nam Chomsky I know I know
generally where he's gonna come from the
I mean I do agree with him about the
fact that we have way too much influence
by corporations in the way that our
governments work and in our daily lives
and stuff like that but I'm not I'm not
a far leftist like him so you know I I
think that interestingly I actually
think that his is a political stuff is
more interesting than his linguistic
stuff because his linguistic stuff back
when I was doing philosophy language I
just never found it interesting at all
you know I read it but you know I didn't
I didn't see it as revolutionary or
anything like that
cataloguers will you delve into capital
in the future
David Harvey's already done that there's
there's no need for for me to go into
capital he's got a great video series on
it he's the only other person out there
doing something like the half hour Hegel
series so I think that's that's great
Bridget tome ISM solves many
metaphysical and epistemological
problems by appealing to the matter form
distinction but is it possible to defend
the formulation of matter form in the
first place for instance how can it's
almost argue against idealism without
first taking it for granted this
fragmenting of reality into matter
inform that is at such a high level of
abstraction that I I wouldn't even know
how to answer it
because I mean when somebody says
Thomism I always ask okay whose dome ISM
are you like actually going to the soma
and working from that are you reading
Gary gula garage are you reading Jacque
more attend are you you know using
Alistair McIntyre very very different
kinds of tome ISM and so I'm very leery
of any generalization about tome ISM you
know as such they do in fact I wouldn't
say they solve many
metaphysical and epistemological
problems they provide explanations of
things that are identified as problems
by using not just appealing but using
the matter form distinction it's only
effective if you can actually parse it
out and is it possible to defend the
formulation of matter form in the first
place
sure I mean there are defenses of that
you know again Tomasz literature right
you know you can read people's
discussions of that and and plenty of
Thomas took on idealism you know within
I mean transcendental tome ism would be
a place to go
rear honor you know Marsha all people
like that if that's that's what you're
into they certainly were engaged with
with idealism I mean you don't really
fragment reality into matter in form
because they're not it's not as if you
ever have prime matter anyway
that's totally uninformed so you know
it's it's a it's a way of analyzing
things oh here's a good one from coha my
question is what age did you first
approach to philosophy and which one is
the most advisable for a newcomer to get
started so I'll answer the second part
first you can start philosophy whatever
I mean starting philosophy is not
something that you have to be anxious
about getting right you're inevitably
going to read something that later on
you're like oh I read the wrong thing
you know just start reading some stuff
and thinking about it and discussing it
with other people whether it's Plato or
whether it's contemporary stuff or
whether it's medieval thinkers or you
know anything in between I first
encountered philosophy as taught as
philosophy in a philosophy class that I
hated in high school and then
encountered it in a religion class not
being taught as philosophy taught by a
substitute teacher and I really enjoyed
it and I was always reading you know
bits and pieces of things some Eastern
thought you know I was very interested
in history so of course I paid attention
to some things in West
philosophy but didn't understand them
that while and you know even as an
undergraduate I you know I didn't have
very good teachers so that's one thing
but I also read very you know
eclectically so you know my path is not
the path I think everybody should should
tread retro gamer is is trying to like
stir things up God loves libertarianism
I've never seen a you know a scripture
that said that and I don't I don't
presume to understand the mind of God
but I mean it could be the case but I
highly doubt it rock heed any thoughts
on post-modernism and its emphasis on
identity politics just resonates with
contemporary left-wing fascination with
identity yeah it's not postmodern
identity politics and post-modernism are
not the same thing you know they're
they're glom together in the popular
mind and I'd say that though the right
wing is just as fascinated with identity
politics as the left-wing are it's just
different identities that they're
they're focused on trevor asks about
about my myers-briggs thing I've never
done a myers-briggs thing I think
myers-briggs is [ __ ] you know any
any class victori principal like that I
don't I don't buy into and you know
people make use of those for all sorts
of silly generalizations III have no
idea what I would actually score but I
don't put any stock in it at all and and
you know this is kind of a running joke
among people who do coaching or
counseling or stuff like that you know
how unscientific the myers-briggs stuff
is but how much people seem to love it
you know especially in business formats
and pastoral formats all right sherry
are you concerned about what Islam is
doing to the world people who say they
believe in God but their actions tell
their knee lists yeah I've been
concerned about that for a very long
time I think that that there there is a
good bit of that in you know what we
call radical Islam or
talat Aryan Islam I don't really like
the word Islamofascism
because I think that what goes on in
totalitarian Islam is is a bit different
than a bit more difficult to combat than
than just plain old you know
garden-variety fascism in part because
it's got it's got deeper roots that said
I don't I don't see that as sort of you
know the face of Islam right and I
haven't really the entire time that I've
been interested in these issues which
law which went you know long before 9/11
and there's plenty of other people who
believe in God and our neo lists as well
there's plenty of Christians I've seen
doing that and I'd say some of the
people involved in the Hindutva movement
in in contemporary India are doing that
as well
Buddhists who are engaging in ethnic
cleansing in Burma
likewise you know so it's not as if
Islam has a monopoly on that and if we
look through our history you know we can
see some pretty horrific stuff carried
out in the West that said that's not as
if religious people have them Napoli on
that either plenty of secularists as
well so all right you know what is your
opinion epicureanism as a philosophy of
life that's an interesting one so we
don't really have that much to work with
right
from ancient Epicureanism we have a few
writings by Epicurus that are preserved
by Diogenes lay our taste in his lives
of the philosophers thank God for that
because otherwise we wouldn't have any
of that we do the Vatican sayings you
know which which which complement that
some you know short piece found in the
Vatican archives we have Lucretius we
have some discussions of Epicureanism by
people hostile to epicureanism like
Cicero or Plutarch
and we have phillyd a mess
a few pieces by him and it's it's
tougher to piece together
a consistent philosophy of life out of
that but I know some people who are
doing it and I think that what they're
doing you know I don't think it's bad I
just don't I think it's rather
incomplete I'd rather walk down a dark
alley with an epicureanism than an
a-list so yeah
Kanade let kenai gal V do you have any
opinions on Alvin planting I heard
William Lane Craig column the modern
Aquinas after laughing for a few minutes
I started wonder if he's worth reading I
will tell you I've never you know read a
Craig book all the way through a page
through and not been impressed planting
a yeah he's okay
he and reinvents a lot of wheels in part
because he like a lot of analytic
philosophers of religion reads very
selectively you know he's got a few
interesting things to say about the
nature of Christian philosophy and
you'll see him mentioned in my in my
book about the 1930s Christian
philosophy debates but the people
involved in that which would be like you
know Maurice blown down a gentle song
Jacques Martin Cabrio Marcel Antonin
soutache they were like light years
ahead of planting or Craig I mean is he
the modern Aquinas definitely not I mean
well what do we mean by Aquinas proud
somebody who's able to take all sorts of
ideas and try to synthesize them into a
grand integrated world perspective well
you kind of have to have a much wider
exposure of ideas that don't you
so I don't I don't see planting uh in
that way
[Music]
Sharp's asks have you heard of Nick land
and if so do you have any thoughts of
him I think I've heard him mention but I
don't know anything about him so I don't
have anything to say about him suppose
there's people are seconding and
thirteen the question on Nick land I
suppose I should look him up and find
out who he is you know this is kind
an interesting side note you know the
more time that you're spending with with
primary literature because you only get
24 hours a day you got to spend some of
that eating and sleeping and doing other
stuff the less time you have with
reading you know contemporary stuff or
secondary literature so I don't I don't
really pay much attention to to that
sort of stuff and I'm not well-read okay
here we go
so okay he's an English philosopher
short story horror writer father of
acceleration ISM as he's been tied with
speculative realism he founded the
cybernetic cultural research unit and I
don't really know enough about him to
say anything here so not sure what it
what what acceleration ISM actually
means this is one of the problems with
isms right people like to name things
and then you're like okay what what
actually is the context for this
let's see your real Lavi do you think
Plato meant the Republic to also be
taken literally with just a metaphor for
the soul the latter books convinced me
he's being serious why not both why not
more I mean it's not as if you have to
take a book that's you know this thick
and have just one single take on it you
can say some passages are supposed to be
you know taken more seriously
others are metaphors like where for
example Socrates says here's a metaphor
for you maybe those things are
metaphorical I mean the the Republic
covers a lot of stuff too
so I don't think you have to have a one
single global thing boy here's we got a
lot more questions so I think I'll stick
around a little bit longer although I
don't know I'll get to all of these and
let's see what we got here mr. Dharam
paji can a person make money through
academia and is it necessary to concrete
your research interests and narrow it
down I'm studying
philosophy but wish to continue a
sociology in psychology yeah you can
make money with academia it's tougher
these days there's a lot of competition
for academic jobs in philosophy for when
I was still on the job market every job
I would apply for we've had about 500
applicants and you know we're moving
more and more here in the United States
to relying on adjunct labor I teach as
an adjunct sometimes and and I do it
because I like to stay in the classroom
and it's nice to have access to
University Libraries but I'll tell you
if you try to make a living as an
adjunct that's a miserable way to exist
and and many people burn out doing so is
it necessary to concretize your research
interests yeah I mean if you want to
write a dissertation you do you have to
have a you know a topic but there's
nothing that says that you can't have a
wide range of interests I mean if you
look at you know people are always
saying well what do you do well I work
on figures all across the history of
philosophy and I also do other things on
the side Dark Star is a good question
what philosophers would you recommend to
increase your understanding of power
dynamics well definitely lots of ancient
philosophers right and you know some of
the medievals would be good to to think
about as well and then you know you you
want to even read people that you might
not necessarily agree with but who have
been incredibly important within the
field like say Thomas Hobbes I don't
agree with Hobbes on a lot of stuff but
I do work on Thomas Hobbes because I
think that he's important for setting
problems and then he didn't go all the
way through to the present there's all
sorts of interesting people you know
talking about power and rewrites are you
a poetry fan which poet do you find the
most fertile for deep thought I mean my
favorite poet is Rilke but that's
because I find him to be very
philosophical that I love I love the way
he writes
I'm not really a poetry fan as a matter
of fact oh I'll admit something here so
what I'm reading like fantasy literature
which you know I do for that like worlds
of speculative fiction and people have
you know like songs or poems woven into
it I often kind of skip through that
stuff it in park as I get kind of I get
kind of bored with it I mean good poetry
is is really great but there's there's
so much stuff where you're like yeah not
really for me
flea-bitten which developing countries
do you see leading the way in future
philosophical thought and putting the
most resources into academia that's a
great question I don't know that I can
really answer that well I can tell you
just based on my own contacts and
experience so China of course right
China's a juggernaut and they they
understand the need to you know support
study of things so but often what they
do is you know very specialized you know
like you're gonna do you're gonna study
this you know oh great so I'm gonna like
work on Schopenhauer the rest of my life
and that's that's it for me you know
India is an interesting place I new work
developing resources and preparing
candidates for the Indian civil service
exam which has an ethics component and
we're talking about civil service we're
talking about people moving up into the
high ranks of civil service so they all
have to pass this ethics aptitude and
integrity exam and I do you know prep
for that and I also help people with the
optional subject philosophy which
includes history philosophy Indian
philosophy social political philosophy
philosophy of religion it's taken pretty
seriously there the teaching I don't
know is is is really that that great
Brazil is another interesting place as
well you know great disparities in
income and wealth there is kind of a
commitment
to teaching some philosophy and I think
you know they're gonna they're
developing economy where else good
question I don't really know I mean I
think Africa as Africa develops
especially as Chinese money pours into
it and resources is going to become a
major growth area and I'd like to see it
be the right kind of growth that
actually benefits people so mr. Dharam
Dharam podgy are you interested in both
the analytic and continental traditions
yeah kind of interested in it I have
done more I've done working in both of
them you know in time the coursework and
teaching and stuff like that and you
know I'm not I don't belong to either I
don't have a dog in that fight I do
history of philosophy I do philosophies
a way of life I think neither analytic
nor continental exhausts what's
available at the time all right let me
go down it seems philosophers are not
taking good care of their bodies do you
love to do some gym give me advice about
how to use philosophy and in doing gym
or getting handsome I can't tell you how
to get handsome because I don't think of
myself as somebody who's handsome I can
definitely say that you know I don't
know about using philosophy and going to
the gym I'll tell you what I did so I
I'm out of shape you know but I I go to
the gym except I haven't for the last
week and a half because I've been so
sick you know I've been going regularly
and improving although I didn't actually
gain and lose any weight I've actually
gained weight that's because I've gained
muscle mass so I haven't reached that
peak where the muscles are gonna start
consuming you know enough calories but I
can see I'm losing fat you know I do
enjoy exercise but it has to be done in
the right way and it's difficult to make
the time for it so what I had to do I
use Google Calendar to schedule my
appointments and the work that I do
during the day so I can keep track of
all the all the crap that I've got going
and I found that if I didn't schedule
exercise in there deliberately like just
like I would like a client you know
meeting or something like that then I
wouldn't get to it I'd say oh I'll do it
later on you know and then I'd be too
tired or you know it's like midnight I'm
like well I'm not gonna go down and work
in the exercise room now you know cuz I
gotta go to sleep I guess I'll just do
it next week or tomorrow or something
like that but by putting it into my
calendar and treating it as a priority
that gets me to do it you know other
people find it very helpful to like you
know have others involved in the process
I like to work out you know on my own in
the gym and have everyone leave me the
hell alone
so I can do my workout but other people
like to go to classes and stuff like
that so if that's what does it for you I
guess you know you don't have to he had
philosophy to do that but you just
figure out what what will help you to
actually go to the gym I think that's
that's important
all right canal is Hagel showing a
glimpse of his materialism when he says
the spirit is a bone he's criticizing
vulgar materialism shown in phrenology
and physiognomies when he says spirit is
a bone he's not endorsing spirit is a
bone he's saying that's part of the
problem Connor what are your thoughts if
any on John Jean Baudrillard I'm
currently trying to write my philosophy
dissertation on his notion of
hyper-reality Baudrillard is an
interesting guy I like him he's easily
misunderstood in part because you didn't
make a hell of a lot of effort to try to
be properly understood but I find I find
a lot of his ideas quite interesting and
well worth thinking out you know the
notion of the hyper real the real is you
know the reproducible all that I think
is pretty cool so yeah I think it's it's
it's interesting that you're working on
him
Ruby does the silver can you give us
your view of what the ancients might
have said about the political
correctness and it's lunacy we're facing
now sure Aristotle would say that 90% of
the people on the left and nine
percent of the people on the right are
ignorant often deliberately ignorant
people who are choosing their positions
misunderstanding justice and should get
the hell out of politics and and keep
their mouth shut when it comes to
culture that's paraphrasing of course
Aristotle talks about the problem in
political breakdown what he calls status
or fashion of people taking you know
getting getting things partly right and
thinking that they've got the whole
right and then demonizing their
opponents Cicero also talks about this
Plato talks about this over and over
again you know if we were to bring
Aristotle into the present he would he
would say that you know both of our two
main political parties are at this point
you know very dysfunctional don't don't
serve the common good and there are
exceptions but those are exceptions so
yeah
Hamilton thoughts on Nassim Taleb stuff
haven't read his stuff haven't been
impressed with with the way in which he
comports himself or the way that his
fans do I've had to block some of them
actually and so that doesn't give me you
know much incentive to spend the bit of
time that I have to read his stuff so
Brian I'm wondering whether or not
you've encountered the work of Allah
seems to be gaining quite a bit of
attention and continental circles yeah
he has been for a long time my wife
actually studied with him and acted in
his play as one of the Ackman's I
haven't read much of his stuff again
something I haven't had time for but you
know he's very interesting figure I wish
I had the time to it I'm just gonna take
a few more questions and then I got a
wrap-up because I have another session I
have to do in in less than an hour for
the half hour Hagel supporters
Thomas as I recall mentioning he used to
lift weights what type of training did
you do and what were your best lists I
did what was called endurance lifting
back in the day and the idea behind that
was medium weights rather than heavy
weights you know medium amounts of reps
and a lot of sets so for example when I
did the bench I did a pyramid going you
know pyramid means like you're going up
and weights 13 sets going up ultimately
the highest I was at was like 175 and
that would be like 4 wraps and then you
know you'd go back down right and it
took about an hour to do and you know
I'd do the same thing for everything
else it was it was pretty intense when I
would do that and then I started doing a
sort of circuit training using dumbbells
at home I just bought myself dumbbells
you know and then I didn't do it for a
very long time
and the reason why I did you know
endurance training or you know stuff
like that rather than power lifting is
my body is not built for that you know I
I don't have big thick wrists like like
some of my relatives do who are you know
I'm a big guy but I'm you know I have a
and I have a wide frame you know broad
shoulders but I'm built for for a
different kind of stuff than
powerlifting I'm not have the bones to
support that kind of stuff so yeah oh
Ken what's your opinion on the sci-fi
works of Ian banks he seems to have
taken particularly interesting views on
the progression of society and synthetic
minds yeah I got to read banks he was
recommended to me by one of the
participants in our our worlds of
speculative fiction series that we do
here locally and boy was it good stuff
I'm looking forward to reading more of
the culture series and even some of his
other stuff that's outside of that so
all right I'm gonna take a few others
Carl do you have any thoughts on
Xenophon Socratic dialogues I ask
because you have no videos on them and I
want to read them alongside Plato's yeah
I mean don't take my not having videos
on something as a sign of whether I like
it or don't like it it's just a matter
of finding time you know and and I I
think the amount of fun is great I
really enjoy him he's an interesting guy
he's very important underrated in the
importance for stoicism I think you know
remember who was II know reading all
right Zanna fond and he asked about
where can I find this this guy so
Xenophon is well worth worth checking
out let me scroll down a lot of
questions here I'm just gonna grab a few
that I can do really easy and then I'm
gonna bring it to a close
SJW cut person what do you think of the
alt-right adopting some of Nietzsche's
philosophical ideas well everybody
adopts someone Nietzsche's philosophical
ideas people on the left you people on
the right do that's one of the things
that happens when you become a famous
philosopher you kind of screwed you know
people are gonna take your ideas and do
weird stuff with them so I think it's
you know when people get things wrong as
a philosopher I'm like well that's not
the what Nietzsche actually said but I
don't think it's particularly the right
who's doing that I think a lot of people
do that
vintage Josh GAD you read any
peer-reviewed philosophy journals not
often not regularly I read articles from
them but that's what I'm doing research
on a particular topic so if I'm like you
know working on Aristotle and pry
racists I'm looking at the articles that
have to do with that sort of thing or or
related topics and they could be from
all sorts of different journals so you
know all right mister
Dharam paaji is asked twice what's your
opinion on champagne socialism or what
we used to call Neiman Marcus ISM right
after neiman marcus the neiman marcus
the the ritzy store you know I think
it's BS right I mean I don't think that
that's that's a very difficult topic if
you're committed to socialism but you're
kind of you know living an elite life
you're not really committed to soul
ilysm and and you might say well it
enables me to like reach more people I
don't buy that crap so as a matter of
fact I think it's better for the elites
quite often to get the hell out of the
way of those of us who want to do
something rather than just taking up the
the forums and the space you know so so
sit Sosa's sochi in your opinion were
there any russian philosophers that had
an influence on continental philosophy
thanks for your advance yeah I mean
there are some who actually like fit
into continental philosophy lamb chest
off important guy
underrated not looked at a lot you know
but but mentioned every once in a while
boris grace has a chapter on him in his
anti philosophy book bear GI EV did to
some degree mostly in terms of
existentialism not a lot of people read
them anymore of course there's you know
Bakhtin Mikhail Bakhtin who's also
volution off as we think it done a lot
of interesting stuff on language and and
dialogue and stuff like that
so those are those are three that are
that are quite important Tony best
authors for understanding structuralism
that's interesting so I mean you
definitely want to read dis so sirs
course on general linguistics you
probably find it kind of boring but it's
worth reading you want to check out Levy
Strauss gonna check out rollin Bart
right
[Music]
and you can't avoid if you really want
to be serious about structuralism
reading AJ grimace
major author available in translation
you can also read them in the French if
you want to you and somebody else I
think who is good to take a look at on
that is America echo you know the semi
semiotic sky he's got some great
discussions about that let's see I'll
take one other question
oh I'll finish on this seven thinker do
you think an rant on Iran did a good
understanding of Aristotle no and I
don't I don't actually think that her
followers do either I think that it's
interesting because Aristotle is a good
guy in her book you know plate of course
is a bad guy and but I don't think she
really understood Aristotle both in
terms of his epistemology and in terms
of his political theory and ethics and
you don't go to Rand for good history of
philosophy any more than you went to
Bertrand Russell who's terrible with
history philosophy as well or you know
other other contentious authors and it's
interesting because her followers tend
to like make Aristotle into a fetish but
those of us who are you know sorry you
might say more Aristotelian we look at
that and we're like wow you it's sort of
like it's sort of like take seeing
somebody take you know somebody who you
love and lobotomize them put some clown
makeup on them and then sit them on
their lap and make them say the things
they want to say that's what I would say
is the treatment of Aristotle there so
all right I'm gonna say thanks to
everybody great questions I do have to
get ready for another thing and I gotta
eat something
before I do that as well glad I couldn't
answer everything but you know I try to
give priorities the first come first
right so
we'll do this again next month we do
this every month also you have the the
we call them philosophy pop-ups here and
on Facebook each month haven't decided
what the topic is going to be for April
but I'll figure something out
those of you'd like to support my work
you can do so on patreon I just go to
patreon.com/scishow of these things man
that's that that's the one thing that we
never can get enough of right is time I
maybe you should do maybe I'll talk
about that for the philosophy pop-ups
that's a great idea actually I'm gonna
talk about time I think people still saw
her I think other stuff all right so I'm
gonna bring this to a close and see you
in the interwebs somewhere else